I can carry my month I'm Kim so I loved
a watch that I was laughing at a minute
and I thought really enjoyed it so
that's what it is it's a silly fun like
take your meets kind of movie yes take
your mind off things it's going to have
a good laugh so I loved in the film how
spicy you were when you sleep happy to
play the baddie in this one of course I
was so excited because she was also one
of the first characters that has been
new characters that's been introduced
into this Baywatch squadron everyone
liked most of the characters that are in
the movie are sort of from the TV show
so I had the liberty and the ability
creatively to be able to do whatever I
want and also victorious such an
absurdly fabulous character indeed like
she wears good to go to the beach and
she doesn't like walking on the sand so
there's a little stool that comes out to
her and she someone asks for a raised
she feeds them to the Sharks I mean
she's crazy it's great but this mean so
much friend there's a crack in the movie
about playing a Bond villain would you
ever consider a Bond villain in real
life
I was like I do actually I like that
yeah because I'm a big fan of the Bond
franchise and I would love to play any
of the characters I mean ideally I would
love to play Bond
oh yeah I doubt that'll happen and leave
my life nothing it can happen what is he
a female bond I don't know if we're
ready for it it'll be great I hope in my
lifetime we get to see you know women
play these iconic characters as
genderless in fact my inspiration for
Victoria was a Bond villain lightning
you know just over-the-top and
narcissistic and everything is about you
and it's so much fun to play that
because I don't consider myself like
that a little bit so to think like that
was different fun amazing I loved it
you're very outspoken in real life and
this is that's about that and I love how
you don't help me always but oh no but I
love it I know how you like you know
responsible internet trolls and you know
you pick up some mega mark for your
friends and I just know you've got like
order Victoria's assets that anyone want
that's for sure
how important is it for you to use your
voice and see how about things that
close your heart I feel like we live in
a world right now where everything gets
magnified
so much and and most of us are afraid to
have an opinion because everything gets
magnified and everyone has an opinion on
the Internet
since when did trolling become
international news first of all it's
trolling for a reason so I don't care I
get so much love and affection from
people on on my social I focus on that
and second of all that's how you should
treat life I was raised by my parents to
have an opinion I was raised to be
fearless I was raised to not be a girl
who's meant to always be quiet and
demure I was told to be the best that I
could be and I wish that for every girl
child on the planet so I love and then
add the line in the maybe when you get
called a [ __ ] and you say it if I were
a man you call me driven I drop my job
love it and do you find the battle of
the sexes an issue in Hollywood is it
like a fit you're not lots of people out
boast about this at the moment
especially I mean I think the battle of
the sexes is a big problem in the world
in whichever field you pick whatever
else it not just entertainment I mean
entertainment gets it's in the news
because we are entertainers but
otherwise you see everyone deals with it
and it's unfortunate that we're in 2017
and it's such a big topic of
conversation that I'm playing a female
villain and the villain is female in it
such as we should have seen so much more
of that in entertainment that should be
norm because female actors are just as
powerful as men but if you see box
office figures the movies that boys lead
are always so much more like numbers
wise so that's a reflection on us as a
society we go and watch those movies a
lot more than we watch with female leads
on a poster so I think it's a mindset
thing where we need to start thinking
that that needs to be uh normal two
things which I really advocate is you
know gender equality for sure and that
doesn't mean like we hate men or we want
to be better than men it's just saying
give us the ability to make our choices
without being judged like you've enjoyed
for such a long time and second is
diversity and this movie stands for both
I mean look at the TV show
Baywatch in the 80s and what it looked
like to what this movie looks like now
to the female characters and they was
always known to sort of be a little
easier
this movie's flipped it completely you
have four kick-ass badass leading ladies
in the movie and each one of them has
such an amazing character and you know
and it's really for the females this
movie I mean look at drinks
I mean that mentoring fields were not
questioned because as long ago a trauma
who is obsessed with the rock she loves
them she seemed about cardboard cutout
of him at her desk she wants to marry
him
do you think he would make good marriage
material and what I had best husband
qualities I definitely think he would
make great marriage material because
I've seen him with his his family and
I've seen him with his kids and I just I
know how much of a family man he is and
that's that the one thing you need in a
husband is honesty I think and that Dad
and Trust and the rock totally exudes
that so you must tell the stuff out
that one is husband is around he's gone
damn it shadow is what is fun maybe to
show you I after hours did you go out
did you have fun together and sing fun
you know it was it was actually really
hard movie to shoot because Miami was
like a hundred degrees we were in the
Sun every day for like 12 to 15 hours
you know for like four months so it was
a comedy but an action and you know I
keep being able to maintain the bodies
and the shape and working out and the
regime all of that was really difficult
but this I think all of us got really
tight we got really close to each other
we spent a lot of time with each other I
mean these guys would even gym together
I see is emotionally like out of juice
oh because I should eyes look at them
and I was like I should go to gym more
often you know you don't you understand
when someone works like I'm your friends
oh yeah I was that person and it was
horrible but it was so great because I
know that this will be friendships that
will last a lifetime
oh that's good he would win an arm
wrestle between the rock that's like
everyone or you yeah right I mean I
think it would be the rock but I think
Victoria oh yeah here's man she would
totally win because she probably have a
truckload of people Michael you know
pulling it all of it